the president restricting travel from
Europe as Koba 19 is officially declared
a pandemic US Vice President Mike Pence
joins us live from Washington where he's
spearheading the efforts on behalf of
the federal government he joins us live
mr. vice president good morning to you
yeah good morning all good to be with
you all right we heard from the
president last night where he talked
about some of the initiatives including
for the most part cutting off all travel
from Europe with the exception of
England and Ireland I think things like
that what has been the reaction to the
White House over the president's move
last night well I think the reaction has
been very favorable across the country I
mean the American people have seen once
again that President Trump has no higher
priority than the health and safety of
the people of this country you go back
to when the coronavirus first emerged in
January in this country the president
again just like he did last night he
took unprecedented action in January to
suspend all travel from China we
quarantined any Americans that were
returning from China to put the health
of America first we issued travel
advisories for Italy and for South Korea
but now the reality is that the
epicenter of the corona virus epidemic
has moved from China and South Korea to
Europe our task force has been tracking
that we brought that information to the
president in real time and yesterday he
made the decision in the Oval Office to
suspend all travel from Europe for the
next 30 days and to be clear Steve every
American that is returning from Europe
will be screened as they return through
13 separate airports and will be asked
to self quarantine for 14 days it's okay
part of the president's strategy we want
to prevent the coronavirus from being
brought into the country and then
continue to focus on those communities
where we have community spread even as
we encourage best practices and
common-sense by every American mr. vice
president what do you say to those
families that have kids in college that
are traveling abroad studying abroad I
know maybe if they're in Italy
either have to stay put at this point or
are they able to come home what about
kids that are in Switzerland and in
Ireland and France Ainsley it's a great
question and I've had kids that have
studied abroad as well every one of
those families should know that their
children can come home they will be they
will be funneled as we say through a
series of 13 different airports and and
then we'll ask them to self quarantine
regardless of their symptoms or what
their conditions they come might be good
they stay well look I I would suggest to
you that now that we that we see that
that 70 percent of the new coronavirus
cases in this country or in the world
are now being manifest in Europe I'd
leave that decision to every family but
there's no barrier to their to their
kids or any any American coming home
they'll go through a process we'll ask
them to self quarantine but but they can
all come home so mr. vice president
62,000 Chinese citizens have been
discharged from the hospital they know
they think if we're to believe them they
only had 15 cases the other day eight of
which we're from Chinese citizens six
came from the outside if success leaves
clues and that massive quarantine of
entire cities has got the number down
that low are you are do you think we
should end up should we do the same
thing as China did after all they
started the whole thing and they seemed
to be on top of this now well we're
seeing some encouraging news from Asia
and the president last night in his
address to the nation said that we may
be able to reconsider our current
posture with regard to China and in
South Korea as a result but make no
mistake about it Brian our our focus
here in addition to preventing
preventing the corona virus from being
brought in and what we learned from our
health experts in the last 36 hours was
that yesterday as of the 35 cases
where we had coronavirus cases about 30
of those states 35 states 30 of those
states actually could trace the contact
to someone in Europe that's the reason
the president took the decisive action
he took but make no mistake about it we
are also focusing on supporting efforts
at the state and local level in
California in Washington state and in
California CDC issued very strong
guidelines for those communities about
public activities large gathering
schools and and will will continue
simply to follow the data on this and
make strong recommendations where we
have what's known as community spread
right but for every American right now
as the president said last night it's
it's a good time to use common sense
wash your hands often clean you know
often use surfaces all that information
is available in coronavirus gov so we're
gonna try and mitigate the spread in
this country but also prevent through
the president's decisive action last
night people from bringing a corona
virus into the United States I think is
from Europe right so just to clarify
you're not going to do what they did in
Wuhan you're not gonna say Manhattan
you're locked down Sacramento you're
locked down you're not going to do that
as of now even though they did that in
China well what I promise you Brian is
that we're gonna work very closely with
state and local officials to give them
the very best counsel from CDC in our
health care experts I talked to the
mayor of New Rochelle yesterday I know
they've established a zone in their
community for for extra countermeasures
against coronavirus I talked to the
governor of New York Washington State
and California yesterday about new
specific guidelines for their
communities but but I want to say to
your viewers just as the president said
last night the risk to the average
American of contracting the corona virus
remains low but we do know that seniors
with serious underlying chronic health
conditions are particularly vulnerable
to very serious outcomes and so we
encouraging best practices for every
American we're focusing on communities
where we have community spread but for
any American that's watching today
that has a family member a loved one
who's a senior citizen with a serious
underlying health condition this is a
very good time to to help and to support
them to be able to avoid public places
and everyone around them to engage in
good hygiene and good practices to
protect those that are most vulnerable
and and and the key is what is now
referred to mr. vice-president as social
distancing we're Pete you just keep a
distance from people around you if
you've got to go to the grocery store
don't come up right behind him you just
never know who might have it I know the
president has called off his domestic
travel he's postponed a rally and a
fundraising event we know that the NBA
has suspended their season the NCAA is
gonna do March Madness without people in
the stands for the most part and then
you've got Anthony foul show yesterday
who said you know it's probably going to
get worse before it gets better
and there's a story out as well that
says that last week Republicans in
Congress were told there's a good chance
of most people in the United States will
be exposed to it it doesn't mean they're
gonna get it but it could be out there
right well look one of the things that
we know about the corona virus from our
experts studying global data is it's
it's it's two to three times more
contagious as a respiratory illness and
so we'll have thousands of more cases
across this country but your viewers
deserve to know that most Americans the
vast majority of Americans who even
contract the corona virus will have
flu-like symptoms and will will fully
recover I talked to a man named clay
Bentley in Rome Georgia yesterday on the
phone he's doing well he's recovering
well and in his personal strength and
his faith have sustained him through
this and it was inspiring to talk to em
three so we don't want as the
president's conveyed we don't want
Americans
be overly concerned we want everybody to
practice good common sense sure but in
those communities there where we have
community spread we're going to continue
to give very aggressive recommendations
as we have in California in Washington
and New York to do exactly what you're
saying with regard to social distancing
and we'll respect the decisions of any
business and a sports enterprise that
decides to cancel events to put the
health of the country first but it's
really important I really believe to
focus on the most vulnerable seniors
with serious underlying health
conditions it's the reason why we're
focusing more inspections we've raised
the guidelines at nursing homes and
we're recommending that that that the
people other than those that have family
members in hospice care special
circumstances avoid avoid visiting
nursing homes over the next 30 days I
love that a lot of these businesses are
making smart decisions I know the
financial market many of the banks here
are saying you can work from home you
can travel to see your family and stay
there and just keep your phone close by
and work using your computer what about
the masks I mean excuse me not the masks
the tests because when you if you feel
like you have those symptoms and you
call your doctor before you show up
right is that what we're supposed to do
call an advance so you don't just walk
in and avoid other people do we have
enough tests out there Ainsley we are
working every single day to clear out
any red tape to make tests more and more
available right now every state lab in
America can conduct testing anyone
reviewers that may have a concern can
call their doctor their doctor can
contact the state lab and determine how
to get a test process I'm also proud of
the fact that that University Hospitals
and and around the around the country
are conducting tests the University of
Washington is doing a significant number
of testing right now for their citizens
that have been impacted by the corona
virus but lastly the president you know
you know he's he said this was a
whole-of-government approach but he also
said this is a whole of America approach
so he's brought in business leaders from
nursing homes yesterday banking
hospitals and the rest but one of the
things we did that's most important on
testing was the president brought in the
leaders of the top commercial
laboratories in the country who as we
speak have already approved a test that
is being spun up it's being sent out to
market quest lab core the largest
commercial laboratories in the country
are working very closely with our
administration we're clearing the red
tape out of the way that's gonna be the
way that in the days ahead we're gonna
we're gonna have broad-based testing
available all across the country right
and just in terms of the numbers that we
woke up with worldwide 118 thousand
cases u.s. confirmed 1110 deaths 36 40
states affected including Washington DC
do you have anything to expand on that
no those are the numbers I haven't
gotten my full briefing yet this morning
but those the numbers that we really
focused on in the president's decision
yesterday though Brian was that the fact
that it two weeks ago Italy had roughly
500 cases as of yesterday they have
12,000 cases Germany was at another
thousand France was at another thousand
that's why the president recognized that
the epicenter of the corona virus has
shifted from China and South Korea to
Europe and that's why he took the
unprecedented step the same thing he'd
done with China to suspend all travel
for 30 days from Europe it's about
preventing the additional flow of it of
the infection from Europe into our
country but make no mistake about it
we're also at the same time focusing on
mitigation strategies in communities
where we have communities spread we're
encouraging best practices for every
American especially for our most
vulnerable population and make no
mistake about it our goal as the corona
virus spreads in this country as it's in
the vast majority who would contract it
will have flu-like symptoms and recover
our goal nonetheless is to hold down
that
overall number as much as possible and
we can we will do that with the
continuing cooperation of American
families schools businesses and states
and that's the vision president Trump
has all of us working together we'll get
through this well these certainly are
challenging times and it's good to know
the president and the federal government
have a plan this vice president thank
you very much we know you are a very
busy man these days thank you thank you
god bless you